here to roast the gop that's not my
style besides
there's nothing i can say about the gop
that kevin mccarthy hasn't already put
on tape
welcome back to cbs morning president
biden used the white house
correspondents dinner to poke fun at his
political opponents including house
republican leader kevin mccarthy who was
recorded saying things he had denied
that he ever said mccarthy told other
gop members of congress after the
january 6 riot that he was
thinking of telling president trump he
should resign mccarthy never got around
to doing that the audio of that
conversation was obtained by jonathan
martin and alexander burns of the new
york times authors of the new book this
will not pass trump biden and the battle
for america's future it is published by
simon schuster which like cbs is a
division of paramount global now the
book covers the 2020 election the
assault on the capital and president
biden's first year in office and it is
deeply reported based on hundreds of
interviews documents and yes recordings
and the authors are with us now jonathan
alex thank you very much for being here
uh congratulations on the book
i would like to say congratulations to
our country but i can't because the book
paints a very disturbing picture of
where we are uh and the recordings are
part of that story uh so jonathan
what was it like listening to not just
that snippet that's been played a
million times but
hours and hours of republican leaders
talking very candidly you know for five
years in washington there's been this
conversation to the effect of you know
in private the republicans really can't
stand donald trump but you want to hear
what they say
behind closed doors what we do in this
book is pull back the curtain we tell
readers we tell anybody who buys the
book this is what they actually think
about donald trump here is that private
conversation that you've heard about and
here it is in black and white and here
it is on tape and it reflects the gulf
the vast gulf between the actual views
of the gop leaders about trump and the
views among voters toward him there are
two very different things party leaders
the old guard they can't stand donald
trump they want him to move off the
stage they want to nominate somebody
else in 24 they believe he's one of the
only things that's undermining their
chances politically and as you guys know
most of the voters in the gop are just
fine with donald trump they still retain
a lot of affection for him that golf is
unsustainable uh i missed the part
though alex where you got where you said
you where you got the recordings from
well
i want to know are there more recordings
yes i do too look we have an enormous
amount of primary source material in
this book and one of the challenges in
telling a story as big as the one that
we tell in the book is trying to unpack
all of that with frankly a limited
amount of space and when you're teasing
the publication of a book when you're
trying to share your material even in a
pretty long excerpt in the new york
times you can only share so much of it
so we're still trying to figure out what
to do with that huge show of material
which by the way is not just about
republicans people are loving the kevin
mccarthy material if they don't like
kevin mccarthy but you know this is not
a book that goes easy on joe biden and
his party either that's what i think is
the beauty of the book guys is that you
do a deep dive on both parties you
reveal that both parties have issues i
mean it seems very very fact-based but
neither party seems to acknowledge you
know what we got problems in river city
here they're so busy blaming the other
as opposed to looking inward you know
it's something that jonathan and i talk
about almost every day is that these two
parties and i think the book shows this
really vividly these two parties are
almost in a competition to see who can
do a better job of keeping the other one
in business right that when when the
leaders of both parties are behind
closed doors they will acknowledge as
you hear with kevin mccarthy but other
folks including on the democratic side
like we have got some real big problems
here and we have some extreme forces in
our party we've got to do something
about it the two parties aren't
identical
but they've got some big problems i do
want to stick with kevin macarthur for
sure second because i think for the
average person reading this book it
shows them something about politics that
they may not understand that i don't
understand so you've got mccarthy in
that private recording saying i've had
it with this guy referring to president
trump and then in the same month just a
few weeks later he's in a picture with
the president basically giving the
thumbs up so how do you make sense of
those two well
so we have an entire chapter that really
captures week by week what we call that
roll back how people like kevin mccarthy
mitch mcconnell went from denouncing
trump in such harsh terms after january
6th to sort of returning to in in some
ways to his good graces and you call it
a horror snapping
head snapping reversal and the reason
it's pretty straightforward mccarthy
wants to be speaker of the house and
that is his paramount goal
and he looks around his caucus and they
just don't care what donald trump did on
january 6. they're more concerned about
what their voters think and their voters
are just fine with donald trump and once
mccarthy figures that out
i've got to be where the caucus is he
goes back to the caucus and says we're
not going to impeach trump and in fact
we're gonna we're gonna patch things up
with trump and before january is out
mccarthy is down at mar-a-lago posing
for that now famous picture with him do
you think the voters really don't care
though i think on the republican side uh
there's a willingness to sort of ignore
or at least set aside concerns about
january 6th and certainly donald trump's
conduct that's the polarized moment that
we're in and that's why it's so sobering
this moment in american politics is um
is is really concerning we we cover a
lot of congress in this book i can just
tell you guys there is an error of
extreme tension in the congress right
now it's almost an era of menace there's
concern about more physical violence the
members distrust each other january 6
had a lasting impact on that institution
does a donald trump endorsement still
hold the same weight
i think it depends case by case look at
ohio tomorrow where there's a primary
for the senate it obviously helped jd
vance it's not a small thing in a gop
primary but it's not necessarily
something that's going to ensure victory
because there's other states for example
like in georgia where trump's biggest
vengeance target is brian kemp the
governor of georgia who wouldn't help
him steal the election and brian
campbell now is in pretty good shape
against david perdue who's the
hand-picked candidate against brian kemp
there so it varies by state and it
really gets to the the bet that
republican congressional leaders
particularly mitch mcconnell made after
january 6 which is that over time donald
trump will fade of his own lack of
momentum right and we're about to see in
primary season a real test of that
strategy it's pretty clear at this point
that trump can't just personally anoint
candidates in every state and district
and race in the country but the real
tell and again this is part of the
backdrop for the whole story of the book
is that even the candidates who trump
isn't endorsing
are running on his ideas and emulating
his style of politics and that's a
that's
people say one thing publicly and
another thing privately and maybe the
voters here don't care but the world is
certainly as you say in the book looking
at us very differently after january 6
aren't they it's one of the things that
we heard over and over again we spoke to
uh some foreign leaders foreign
diplomats uh for the book we talked to a
lot of members of congress who have been
overseas over the last year and they say
that just at every turn they get asked
you know is the united states really
okay yeah and they can't really answer a
confident yes to that
you couldn't either in the book either
and talk about sobering talking to
people like tony blair the former prime
minister of the uk malcolm turnbull from
australia and they're asking us is
america still america are you guys going
to be okay because the world depends on
america america is the anchor how did
you answer that question jonathan
we're not sure it remains to be seen but
our reporting in the book doesn't give
us a lot of confidence but here's the
good news ultimately this is the hand of
the american people the voters control
our destiny and they're going to be able
to make choices in 22 and 24. but after
reading this book they're going to have
eyes wide open the president is still
very optimistic at the dinner which we
expect him to be but he was very
optimistic and very confident yeah about
where we're heading a lot of nervous
people in washington want to know if
there's more recordings wanna let them
rest easy this morning no we do not
thank you stay tuned all right
i didn't catch you where'd you get those
recordings
yeah sorry washington no good stuff
ahead jonathan martin and alexander
burns thank you guys very much
appreciate it the book is called this
will not pass and it goes on sale
tomorrow
coming up next